yesterday
with youtube's problems right oh wow
yeah that's right
we're live okay so we're officially live
with episode number 32 of the podcast
gentlemen good to have you back
uh i think we're doing one more this
week but we're taking the entire week
off next week
uh for christmas and then we'll be back
the following week so we are going to
next we're not going to have any podcast
next week not tuesday
not tuesday not thursday not nothing
you get the content it's going to be
okay it's i just found this out i just
want you to know you're going to be all
right first of all aren't you going to
miami before christmas yeah i am but i
i i got to change myself so so when you
go when you go what do you celebrate
when you go christmas what are you
celebrating with the family
do you guys put the whole santa claus
you guys do all that we do the hanukkah
stuff we do the christmas stuff we're
throwing a little sprinkle on some
kwanzaa we don't give a [ __ ] i tell you
what you know adam the other day did a
very special little treat you know
gave everybody a gift gave me got me a
50 uh a gift card to
yard house but but what's impressive is
the fact that you got paula scarcita a
gift card to the gecko the guest that's
favorite part 25. don't don't 20 25
that's good for a pizza and a beer for
that guy there's a shout out right there
for yard house and gekko you know that's
uh so so yeah
what did you learn that day that i
thought what did you learn
what's your what's the minute what's up
well in judaism there's something called
the menorah the nora
the eight candles yep eight crazy nights
we all saw adam sandler's movie in his
song
but in the middle the one in the middle
is called the shamash
it's the it's the teacher it's the yes
it's the worker candle
like the worker that teaches and i said
that's pbd
the man in the middle how to write all
my jews out there yesterday i'm i'm
talking to this one realtor in fort
lauderdale and she keeps asking me where
are you from
i said i'm from iran what why is your
last name be david
i said because i'm a syrian no no i said
no i'm syrian but david means
do you know what it means i see i know
what it means it means house of david
but do you know you're not a syrian i
said i'm a syrian says you are a jew
yeah as i'm telling you i'm a syrian it
says yes but you're an assyrian
that comes from a lineage of a jew you
are a jew now she's a jew you're trying
to convince me i'm a jew
i said do you know how many people have
tried to tell me my entire life that i'm
a jew i'm telling i'm a syrian and
armenian anyways
the jewish community very proud to
convince you you're a jew well you know
why though
does she know more about houses now tell
me why i'm a jew well there's a lot of
jews with the last name
ben yeah that means son of bet means
house exact house so you could teach her
something she tried to teach you
she tried to wrangle you and rope you in
and request i wasn't going to teach her
anything because i was negotiating when
you're negotiating you don't
you just kind of agree on it yes so
congratulations you are now a jew
i am now for that house you'd convert
right yeah
listen i'll tell you what you throw the
house in before
knock a million bucks off i am now a
jews you're all good nice all right so
we got a lot of things to cover here
today a lot of things to cover here
today
if you if you guys don't know adam was
doing backflips yesterday yesterday
electoral college came out with joe
biden adam was in tears he was i found
him next to one of the cubicles and
tears crying crying
thank you god it was the most incredible
prayer i saw very much guys i don't know
how to tell you this
i don't think trump's gonna be the
president i don't know if he's going to
be able to pull this off tom
you say that every one of these
milestones but i'm still holding out
hope i have not given up
you're going down it is not officially
he's got a few things even william barr
jumped ship tom's like i'm holding on
baby
got some ridiculous topics gearing up to
buy your house and lease it back to you
really interesting story of easy knock
which we'll get into
i like it hopefully here in a minute
economists urge new york to hike taxes
on billionaires and one moment cuomo
says
hey stick around the other moment he
says no we have to raise taxes so new
york and by the way i don't know if you
saw yesterday or not new york cuomo said
uh him and de blasio yesterday announced
new york be ready for a full-on shutdown
they just announced that tough place and
they're getting a huge snowstorm
tomorrow lucky people
oh my goodness that's when you know the
weather is great so with elon musk
moving to texas
the world's three richest people
officially live in states
where you pay zero state taxes just so
you know the top three and we'll cover
those top three
uh florida the new wall street lots of
good things going on right now with
florida we talked about it last week we
will get into a different angle today
queens business owners
haunted by amazon's lost emmet pandemic
which they were supposed to move there
and now they're frustrated about it
apple's coming out with a new app to
compete against fitness apps like
peloton
everybody's all the silicon valley
companies are taking a different
approach to the pandemic
we'll cover some of that with google
apple twitter salesforce microsoft
is not silicon valley but we'll cover
some of those companies bar
william barr to resign as attorney
general which obviously is a very good
day for adam when that happens
russian hackers suspected of spying
the us on the u.s government including
treasury and commerce departments
and then we got uh farmers in india
farmers in india big story there by the
way very big story there i mean
the data on that is insane african
countries borrowing billions from china
you got the first person that got the
shot you got mark cuban that gave uh
uh jj berea a nice contract before he
left just a lot of topics to cover
sanctions on turkey time person of the
year
wildfires uh i say we start off with
don't skip over uh which one did i skip
which one well the gretzky oh the
gretzky card i mean we gotta talk about
that
kidding me it was a good week it was a
good week so i bought two cards two
uh 17 months ago yeah gretzky cards i
got a phone call from a guy who was a
good contact of mine from pasadena
and he says uh can can you come up with
a half a million dollars in the next 24
hours let me just check my package
i said what do you mean he says i got a
seller that wants cash now he doesn't
want to go through the whole 90-day to
six-month auction series
i said what are we negotiating he wanted
six hundred thousand we settled on 540.
and i bought the two cards i sent green
one real nice guy he gave the car to
tikrun
the money hadn't even hit his account
really yeah he trusted tikrun that tells
you a lot about tikrun's character
so we bought the two cars for 540. last
week
it sold at heritage auctions for two
million ten thousand dollars
a record both of them yeah thank you one
of them sold for 720
the other one sold for one two nine
the most expensive hockey card ever sold
and then yesterday i had a bunch of
calls where different guys trying to get
them to keep lose your seat
hey let me ask you a question when that
auction's going on are you sweating it
out are you watching it second by second
are you really the last
hour entertaining i gotta tell you
because the last couple hours the
auction you're looking at you're like
okay
it's at eight hundred thousand dollars
the other car's at 3 30. you're like
yeah
it's cool you know you're gonna walk
away with nice you know 1.2 million and
then all of a sudden
850 900 915.
sick then 925 950 975 million
million it just kept going up and going
up and the other one kept climbing and
then last minute
it stops no one's bidding anymore so two
million ten thousand so
you turned 540 000 into over 2 million
bucks
in less than two years 17 months 17
months so
you know year and a half that's a 200
percent
plus rate 233 232 months i i tell you
one thing here
card industry is gonna is gonna blow up
in the next 10 years you've been saying
that i've been seeing this for a long
time
we want to let our you know viewers in
on why you think that well i explain to
why it is it's basic math
here's a couple things to be thinking
about it's a non-regulated
industry with private equity firms
getting into it
so jordan's got 300 psa 10 rookie cards
1986 flea right
they're gonna go out there and buy a
hundred of them the private equity so a
week before the last dance
jordan's cards were selling for 25 to 30
thousand dollars
a week after last dance documentary ends
it's selling for 160 to 200
000 so from 25 to 160 200 000
literally in six weeks is what the cars
go to private equity firms come and buy
a hundred of them
they sit on them then anytime it goes on
an auction they go over
bid on the card they don't buy it for
160 200 000
they buy it for 4 500 000 so it
increases the market because they own
100 of them
and it's non-regulated so it's not like
somebody can come and say it's market
manipulation
no one can say that it's there's no sec
there's no finra
nothing like that and now they have apps
where you can buy funds meaning you can
buy
a percentage of a patma homes card
percentage of a
jordan rookie card kind of like a mutual
fund yeah so it's getting even more
people involved it's a very interesting
industry
plus you can't print anymore there's
they already exactly exactly
and now that they have the credibility
of psa
you know grading cards it's kind of like
equifax transunions it's a whole
different industry so question because i
know we want to move on to a lot of
topics
private equity firms p your firms are
jumping into this business you know
big guys like you pumping in a half a
million turning that around
what couldn't the average person out
there that's got five thousand dollars
to invest ten thousand invest a thousand
invest twenty thousand to invest don't
do anything what do you recommend they
do not do
anything by yourself that you don't know
about go with somebody that knows what
they're doing
and get on the trend like if if
if you if you are thinking about being a
stock a broker you're thinking about
being a
day trader you're thinking about being
an investor into businesses
how do you do it do you just go start
giving people money that you want to
invest into business no you go study a
warren buffett
you go study some of the biggest
investors of all time and then you buy
into a money manager
a money manager that you trust and you
go with them then you start kind of
going into it
if you're going to be day trading kind
of like cards professionally
you got to know what you're doing don't
just go out there and throwing money at
cards
so you do believe in this asset class
big time
percent i know so pat are you saying
don't spend 20 grand on a 2019 mike
trout coward
is that a bad investment oh that would
be anything great if you had if you had
if you had the right mic
i said 2019 no not 29. you're right if
you're not even you go into this thing
you can get
i will i wouldn't do it if you have no
clue what you're doing do not do it this
doesn't want to do but here's the thing
you buy the right cards there's no way
you're going to lose money on cards the
only way you lose money on cards is when
the player does something stupid
which like an o.j simpson type of thing
that card is nobody wakes up in the
morning saying
i can't wait to buy an o.j some rookie
card you know oh my gosh
the guy was the greatest running back of
all time no they say
there's no way in the world i'm going to
brag about having an o.j simpson rookie
card right so except for our friend
borat
or whatever that's a different story
you have to see the video so what should
i do with my kwame brown rookie card is
that going to take
that one you give to an exhibition okay
guys you give to an ex of yours okay
all right by the way uh let's see here
what did we get into what story did we
get into first we got a lot of good a
lot going on pat
you tell us yeah you know what let's go
talk about this whole wall street
situation here wall street
wall street is gearing up to buy your
home buy your house
and lisa back to you grown group of wall
street owners of single-family rental
homes have ramped up
their fundraising in anticipation of the
millions of americans who could be
forced to turn over or sell their homes
amid the financial stress of the
pandemic the four-year-old firm easy
knock has established itself
as a name and so-called the sales lease
back
transactions in which homeowners sell
their company
sell the company their property then
rent it back easy knock ceo jared
kessler
told business insider that a financial
partner recently committed to provide
it with a credit line that will allow it
to acquire
500 million dollars of homes a sum that
would more than triple its current
portfolio
which is nearly 200 million what do you
think about this easy knock idea you
know the
my first impression i didn't want to
like it i i didn't i think there had to
be a catch
right are these guys you know what's the
fine print say once they buy your home
from you how soon can they
sell it again and then are you screwed
or how long can you actually lease it
but you know what if you're stuck in a
bad loan or if you
need to borrow some money you need some
equity you don't have to do a home home
equity loan
it kind of makes sense and it seems like
the market right now is ripe for it
you can stay in your own home you can
rent instead i mean do they have to pay
for repairs then
i mean it's fascinating i just don't
think 500 million dollars is a lot of
money
behind this company to do it at a huge
level i was expecting
multiple billions behind these guys to
really go after but maybe they're not
going after the really high-priced homes
either
but man i don't know i don't know if i'd
want to be one of the first ones doing
this thing just in case but
on the surface i think it sounds like a
pretty good deal
adam they're they're also going after
single home single-family homes
meaning uh just one family home it's
probably like two maybe three bedrooms
got it smaller homes and their previous
credit line was 200 million
so let's just say 500 million divided by
250 000
is that an average let's just say 250
000 2000 homes
at 250 000 yeah okay so you're
collecting rent from 2 000
people essentially what do you think
about the idea well it reminds me of
something that i'm pretty familiar with
which is reverse mortgages i mean this
is something that a lot of seniors have
taken advantage of as you get older and
you might not want to have to pay your
mortgage and you know these
reverse mortgage companies come in and
offer you to
essentially to be able to live out your
house and buy you out
there has been regulation set in place
where the
you know people have taken advantage of
this like tom said there
there could be if you're one of the
first people to do it read the fine
print see what's going on
um you know there could be some you know
shadier activity going on but this
sounds like a
sort of a reputable wall street type
esque type firm that's bringing this
together and you know look i'm a huge
fan of renting
and especially if you're young out there
and you're listening to this
don't tie yourself into a mortgage
especially if you don't know what your
next
next five moves are to use uh use a
quote from pbd
if you don't know where you're gonna be
living in the next 6 12 18 24 months
and you somehow ended up in a mortgage
here this might be a great opportunity i
mean what are the three things that
everyone who has a house has to pay for
that if you're renting you don't have to
pay what i call the big three expenses
your freaking property tax your
insurance and your maintenance and that
stuff that you have to cover
if you own your house if you're just now
renting your house
in the house you want to be in
nonetheless and you don't have to pay
property tax
maintenance deal with the nonsense with
that like i can't even screw in a
freaking light bulb now i don't have to
deal with maintenance and i don't have
to pay for my freaking home insurance
you know living in california with
wildfires and
and in florida with floods and mud
mudslides and tornadoes you know if they
have that worry you could still live in
your house
and and obviously they said you're in
financial distress this could be a
win-win so read the fine print but
for the right i wouldn't make sense i
would be curious of the math
because a lot of times when things like
this happen you have to know reverse
mortgage
gets a lot of heat and there's a lot of
people that get in trouble with reverse
mortgage i don't know how much you're
looking to reverse mortgage the formula
i think 63 years old et cetera et cetera
exactly what i wrote down was what you
started talking about reverse mortgage
and a lot of seniors were taken
advantage of a lot of seniors were
taking advantage of it in the early days
yeah because tomorrow
selling it on the early day came out
with regulations
it's so fine lined the way you do the
math it's not
it's not easy to do today but i also
look at it with another thing that you
do on a daily basis
life settlement it's a very important
thing to go there as well yeah life
settlement is you buy an insurance
policy so if i'm a
if i'm a 78 year old today and i'm
sitting on a 5 million dollar insurance
policy that i cannot
pay the premiums a person like adam
comes and decides to buy the policy from
me
and you go to your investors and they
come out and they'll say we pay we'll
pay what for the five million dollars
20 yeah if it's 20 i'm 78 years old you
pay me a million dollars up front a hell
of a deal
they take to 5 million with the life
expectancy scene if this person is going
to live up to
7 85 years old i take that additional
four million dollars divided by seven
years
then i'm making a nice little return
over a seven year period fifteen percent
let's say
the client is happy because the client's
sitting there saying i'm getting to live
with my million dollars rather than that
5 million is going to
somebody that's no longer here i'm no
longer married i no longer have my wife
my wife died my husband died what am i
going to do with additional insurance
policy
so that makes sense in those situations
live settlement of course
but in this case if the math favors
them listen this this is you understand
what i'm saying so meaning
if the way you get my house is okay
listen i'd like to give you my quarter
million dollar house and i'd like to
rent it from you no problem
what is your approach well we go get
comps what do they sell for
comps 268. okay great we'll give you 240
for it is that what they do
do they go 28 000 before market or do
they give you the 268.
that's the part where i'm curious about
on how they make this work
but the reality of it is i'm surprised
they're one of the first to do it
i'm surprised this is a great idea to do
something like this it's a great
business model yeah
because you're in a distressed right
you're in a situation where you kind of
have to make a decision
take it don't take it you don't have to
take it but we're here for you if you
want to do something with this
it's an option that never existed that's
the one thing i say about live
settlements
is that it's an option if you want to
keep your house and pay your mortgage
keep your house pay your mortgage you
don't need to
talk to me about this kind of thing you
know one thing that i learned when i
entered
the life insurance industry and life
settlement business was it truly was the
wild west in the early
to um early 2000s 2004 2005 2006.
it was not regulated it was wild west
commissions were out of control people
didn't understand what they were signing
up for they're definitely
so you know my firm was one of the first
firms that was like hold on hold on this
is
like out of control we got finra came in
we had a broker dealer come in
did it the right way next thing you know
2008 happened regulations set in and
it's been nothing but good things for
the industry
life settlement yes and live settlement
had a black eye a very black guy
even worse than reverse mortgages but my
point is it starts with a good idea
there's going to be people that are
going to abuse abuse
regulation sets in and you know
good things will happen the problem is
when there's over regulation like
you know being in the life insurance
business with the dol and the d
you know everything that was happening
in 2016 that could have crushed
suitability versus fiduciary that you
know all that now you're really talking
dirty to them oh yeah they're loving
these wardrobes i'm going to talk to you
all about being a douchebag
all that good stuff exactly but anyway
the point is i met
one of these guys that was doing live
settlement one the bigger guys and he
had a uh mammoth in his headquarters no
joke he had a
real life size down in wake up yeah like
partners
live partners yeah one over there and i
think there was mammoth yeah willie
mammoth
a dead one a dead one no a live one bro
that would have been another one was the
woolly mammoth alive or dead
i need to know so are you talking about
one of those prehistoric things yes oh
my god
full disclosure
but what happened when you saw this
woolly mammoth hey you got scared first
like dude what is this a metaphor for
why do you have a mammoth in your office
i mean does that mean you're mammoth i
can tell you they were killing it at one
point yes sir but then they ended up in
jail i know they
it wasn't so the point is when you like
there's you probably stole maybe you
don't trust an office with a mammoth
maybe it's a you know you next time you
see
that office that's right yeah i think we
need to make that again i'm wondering if
it's alive dad he doesn't know what's
going on i'm telling you it wasn't alive
it wasn't alive it wasn't alive okay all
right next let's talk about new york
let's talk about new york you know
there's a million people over a million
people right now in new york
remaining unemployed that's a big number
by the way okay billions of dollars in
budget cuts to essential
services and institutions are beginning
thousands remain eligible for state or
federal unemployment assistance
in this moment a fiscal emergency would
be a moral and economic failure for new
york's legislature an executive to leave
this money on the table
they're talking about the billions of
dollars economists urged new york to
hike
tax on billionaires taxed on
billionaires progressive policies
advocates are ramping up pressure for
wealth tax in new york
as the state's budget hole grows and
neighboring new jersey already has
chosen to increase tax on millionaires
50 economists from across the nation
sent a letter to cuomo
and the state's legislators let
legislative leaders this week in support
of a proposal on two tax hikes
on new york's billionaires the letter
arrived as the legislator
gears up for a full session schedule
that will largely revolve around
resolving the state's more than eight
billion dollar budget cap which is
expected or worse in the following years
look i mean there's a bunch of people
here involved that are saying we got to
do something about it
the economy say the analysis also
included in the envelope
to state leaders predicts an immediate
revenue bump to a tune of 23.3 billion
and then an additional 1.2 billion
dollars in subsequent years while the
pandemic
continues to clobber economic it's a
scary time to be over there
in new york new york's billionaires
increased their net worth
during this period from march 18 to
october 13
by 13.2 percent yeah it's unbelievable
you know i used to be 100
against taxing the rich the mega rich
they earn the money it's their money
why the hell should the government come
in there and take a higher proportion of
it screw that right yeah
i got to tell you i'm flipping and i'll
tell you why it's because of the
zuckerbergs of the world and some of
these other
jokers these billionaires that got bited
and elected okay
this is what you wished for now you deal
with it i mean you did not know that
this was coming down the pike
and the other thing is how can you trust
the government to even do something
23 billion extra for new york they're
going to screw that up somehow you know
they just think low-hanging fruit it's
not like there's some visionaries that's
going to fix
infrastructure or do anything like that
so i say go get
in california and new york tax all those
guys the google founders
eric schmidt dorsey all these biden fans
tax them
do it i mean since they were so in favor
of
biden and extra taxes and they're the
ones electing him
deal with the consequences and i'll say
another thing too did you look at this
panel of people that are recommending it
bernie sanders elizabeth warren these
are socialist
communists i mean calling the shots of
course they're going to want to take all
the money from the rich
this is a scary thing and here's the
other thing too if these billionaires
still live in a state where you're
getting hammered
locally by your state taxes man that's
another thing i mean a lot of these
smart guys have already bailed
tom i'm confused by your answer uh so
you're the republican
who wants higher taxes on the wealthy
you're agreeing with bernie and
ocasio-cortez but obviously
you think they're socialists and
communists i
did not think you were going to go this
direction i thought you would have been
uh
really really upset that they were going
to tax the wealthy you're
you're confused these days trump's in
he's out
i respect i respect the fact that you're
not just going down you're towing the
company line
it's interesting i respect it though um
look
this is something that cuomo has been
talking about for a while new yorkers
have been leaving
uh new york in droves californians have
been leaving california in droves we've
seen silicon valley people moving
um this is scary i mean if you're
already living in new york
and you're a billionaire you're already
paying ridiculous taxes whether it's
income taxes capital gain tax
state income tax whether you're your
firm might be in new jersey
i saw one person who lives in new york
but their firm is in new jersey so
they're paying new jersey tax and new
york tax
something that you asked the other day
is at what point do you leave and this
is something that cuomo needs to
be very aware of you mean he offered
sort of jokingly like don't leave please
i'll cook you dinner remember that whole
thing
uh something that i do agree with tom
that he did mention something
that we've we've talked about the
k-shaped economy where the rich get
richer
and the average working person you know
is struggling and that's
exactly what's going on here um in new
york is that the rich have gotten richer
why stock market clearly why why what
why have the rich count rich and the
poor haven't gotten
why are the poor getting poor rich
getting rich for the most part it's the
stock market i mean obviously if you're
it depends on what you're defining as
rich
you know if you're the working class
person that literally has to show up
to work meaning you're a bartender
you're a waitress you
you know you work for the airlines you
work for in a hospitality industry
you're a
hotel front desk person and you have to
show up to work and your work is getting
shut down
i mean you've highlighted many
restaurant owners who have business have
suffered
this is out of your control these
businesses i mean you see what's going
on in california
those people have suffered tremendously
if you could work remotely
from anywhere and we can i'm sure we're
going to talk about what still
so what are you saying are you saying
raise taxes what is your point i'm not
saying that you should raise taxes i'm
saying it at what point when taxes do
get raised do these billionaires say
[ __ ] it i'm out i'm moving towards
you what do you do give them counsel new
york's listening right now
do you agree with sanders and aoc saying
raise taxes on the wealthy
i think in new york or what do you do i
think at some point
something's going to have to give are
you going to listen to that i mean this
is why
this is why tom is even like i don't
know do i agree do i i'm
saying billionaires i'm not saying
millionaires should have their taxes
raised but these clowns yes
why why billionaires not millionaires
you know what because these people annoy
me
number one why because of how
hypocritical they seem
how how a lot of these people own social
media companies have started social
media companies but these are new
these are new yorkers these are wall
street we're talking about i know it's
hard it's really hard
so let's see
wall street people why tax billionaires
dub
like as much as you can but leave
millionaires alone why why
tax billionaires but not millionaires
because i don't think the billionaires
would feel it as much as the
millionaires but believe me i am not in
favor of more taxes
how do you know that how do you know
that how do we know that how do we know
that tax and billionaires they're not
going to feel it as much as millionaires
are
how how do we know i'll just answer that
uh by what mark cuban said one time he
says there's no uh
describe the difference between being
you know a
you know a meg a millionaire that has
200 million dollars in net worth as
opposed to a billion he says there's no
no comparison
i mean you don't notice anything when
you're a billionaire so that's my
baseline judgment on the fact that if
they tax them for a few hundred million
more
they'll figure something out or they
won't even miss it yeah but how do you
so
so do you tax the guy that averages 45
minutes a game because he's the best
player in the league
and you tax him 10 minutes because he
can afford it and give him to a
lesser player is that what you gonna do
so so but let me explain to you where
i'm going with it
so you guys so you know who's the best
player in the league give me the best
lebron
okay so how many minutes does the
average 40 minutes 45 minutes ago
let's just say average it's not 45 it's
40 at this stage they're trying to get
them at 39 to 40 minutes 40 minutes okay
i think it's too much tax the
billionaire it's lebron you got to bring
him down to 30 minutes it's not fair for
him to get 39 minutes give the other 10
minutes to
a benchwoman but but the point i'm
trying to make is
here's a guy lebron is getting underpaid
i'm not a lebron fan you guys i'm not a
lebron fan
he's getting underpaid he's getting an
85 million dollar contract for two years
that's 42 million dollars that's a
hundred million dollar your player
if ronaldo is getting a hundred million
dollar your contract this guy's got to
be getting a hundred million dollar
account
getting it off the court but go ahead
not the point they're also getting it
off the quarter okay he should be
getting 100 million dollars
why tax the billionaire here's a guy
that spends a million and a half on his
body every year
now is he has he always been doing that
no at 18 years old he couldn't afford to
spend a million and a half on his body
but at 34 years old when most of these
nba players at 34 that are kicking back
they've already made their 200 million
dollars or starting to want to
leave the league and they put on weight
their belly comes at all you're looking
at lebron look at the way he does
lebron to me is the same thing as a
billionaire is in new york okay
if a billionaire non non uh what do you
call it
a generational wealth transfer billion
i'm talking about the legacy
self-made the 64 not the not the 64
of billionaires are self-made just
everybody knows this 83 percent of
millionaires are self-made
64 of billionaires are self-made which
is what 36 of them are
not self-made yeah set those aside say
those numbers again
64 of billionaires roughly is self-made
so two out of three billionaires are
self-made
self-made one-third family like a walton
like one of those guys that got the
money from the family eight out of ten
83 according to a fidelity article
83 of millionaires are self-made sick
okay your hope out there for all of you
did you get your money from your mom and
dad no no yeah you made your money based
on who you're live settlement you're a
you're a you're a self-made guy right so
this is the challenge this is the part
that we have to be very very
careful with because we typically
indirectly we will comfortably pass not
punishment but pass the pain
to somebody that is not us okay full
disclosure i'm not a billionaire so
i'm not here sitting protecting
billionaires so it's not like i'm
sitting here saying hey
why are you defending billionaires so
much i think it's more like
here's a question for me for me to talk
to some of these politicians about
hey you know poor these people that are
going through
tough times and they're having such
difficulties okay
no problem let's talk about them what's
your long-term goal for these guys
give me your long-term goal for these
guys say i'm poor say i'm not making a
lot of money
say i'm one of the guys that's
unemployed right now say i'm one of the
guys that's struggling right now so i'm
one of the guys you want to send to 600
a month what is your long-term goal and
aspiration for me
you understand the question i mean i
like that question what's your term you
can give them a stimulus what
is your long-term aspiration for me
meaning
if i yesterday two days ago tico i said
something to my son
bothered me on sunday we're at lunch i
said something to him really bothered me
yesterday i told jenas i gotta get out
of here i went to school i had to have
the kid come out of class
for me to go sit with them and i said i
need you to look at me he's holding my
hands he's thinking he's in trouble i
just want to know you're not in trouble
i said daddy said something yesterday
stupid to you and i'm just here to tell
you i was wrong
don't listen to what daddy said
yesterday that is wrong
whatever i said to him it's a comment
there's nothing you would it's nothing
that you would jennifer send the kids or
something
it's nothing that was crazy but i don't
want him to
think that he has to change as a human
being to win in life
right so i have to breathe life into my
kid
i have to say i believe you one day
can be dot dot dot and manage
expectation for life right
you're working with me when you came
over here i had to say what adam i
believe one day
you can be dot dot dot i cast the vision
kai one day
i think you can run one of our companies
invited to me you say let's put five ten
million dollars into a company this
one day i believe right okay okay
politicians
to the poor people that are struggling
asking money from you you want to send
them
all these stimulus money what do you
envision me being one day
what is your goal with me tell me what
is your goal with me
it's a question is the goal for me to
stay in this situation
is the goal for me to constantly rely on
the government would you be happy if i
become a millionaire one day
would it bother you if i become a
millionaire would it bother me if i
become a billionaire
would you be bothered if i'd become the
next zuckerberg from a poor guy becoming
a billionaire creating
a hundred thousand jobs would it bother
you if i'm you know
amazon jeff bezos and i create a million
job would that bother would you be
offended by that
my politicians meaning do you want me to
get out of being poor
yes yes of course yes i don't know if
the answer is yes so you're saying you
asked that to politicians i don't think
how do they respond to that no i'm
asking them what is your outcome how do
they respond to it it's not a
masculinity a republican
politician would say yes period yeah so
so then
so okay let's just say republican
politician says yes so let's just say it
is yes
okay do you have a problem with me being
a billionaire one day do you have a
problem with me to have a racks to
riches story go from zero to being a
billionaire one day does that bother you
am i a bad person now i was poor
i had nothing you loved me because i
voted for you
i busted my ass i got out of being poor
you no longer have to send me a check
i take care of my family i take care of
everybody you don't wake up in the
morning saying we have to bail out the
bed david family
that's not something you think about
anymore i'm a billionaire now let's just
say
if i become a billionaire did i do
something bad am i a bad person now
am i like an evil billionaire rich guy
that wants to abuse me is that what
happened
are you sitting there saying thank god
freaking one guy at least got 20 000
people working for him
that we don't have to worry about paying
those people you know unemployment
who's the hero and who are we selling as
a hero so here
these guys are sitting around saying
well let me tell you new york is having
a lot of problems because of stupid
policies
based on the politicians deciding to
shut down all the restaurants
and these restaurants statistically we
can't show that people are getting
covered from these restaurants
they could have worn masks we could have
set up a better situation on seating
but yeah oh now that we're struggling
because we shut down and through so many
restaurants out of business let's tax
the rich
where the hell do you come out with this
kind of a solution you made the decision
to shut down restaurants now you want to
tax the rich
how do you come up with these policies
trump sorry if
you are in a bad financial situation
right now new york is because your
policies suck
so maybe you have to take an inventory
of your policies
don't every time when you screw up
saying let me go tax the billionaires
because you know what the billionaire is
going to say here's a one thing you will
never miss
i've always said this never in our
business
we have builders people that want to go
out there and build a business okay
you never ever ever
do anything to hurt your builders
in in the philosophy of the book of
barbarians to bureaucrats the guy talks
about there's a prophet
he comes up with an idea then there's
barbarians who are willing to go to war
let's go let's go do this i believe in
this let's go
then there's builders that are willing
to build something
let me build structure then there's
explorers we should go explore over here
to see if we can build this business
into australia
we should go explore this market then
comes the administrators
oh we should create some rules and
regulations which you need sometimes
then it shows up the bureaucrats and the
aristocrats you know who the bureaucrats
and aristocrats are
politicians these are the guys that are
sitting afterwards saying well now that
we're running a big company with all
this money here
i think what we need to do is spend that
money who the hell are you
you ruin every company you ruin every
city you ruin every state you ruin every
country
these bureaucrats and their described
who knows what the hell they're talking
about why don't you go create some jobs
for people instead of going attack some
billionaires okay now listen you make a
very compelling argument for the
billionaires and here's my question why
can't they
say something for themselves here's my
problem emotion creeps into this okay
when you see something like this what
what's our reference point it's michael
bloomberg
okay who pumped 500 million dollars into
the state of florida to beat trump
why aren't they saying something
publicly that we want to protect our
money
we don't want to elect these people that
are going to tax us
even more i would like to hear it from
them and i don't
same thing in california you can't lump
the two in together but i wish there
were a few more outspoken
they can't billionaires okay they can't
okay you know why they can't
unfortunately why can't
because it's gonna hurt their business
forget about a bloomberg forget about
bloomberg because bloomberg is sitting
in a wood situation bloomberg is worth
70 billion dollars at this point
okay bloomberg you know what's 500
million dollars to bloomberg
it's the same as you having seventy
thousand dollars and
giving five thousand dollars to somebody
okay it's not not even
seventy thousand dollars uh uh seventy
thousand
no no no seventy thousand dollars are
you giving five hundred dollars to
somebody yeah
that's what he did yeah five hundred
here's 500 bucks bro it's okay hey man
i'm running something i got i'm doing a
run charity run can you give me some
money you got 70 in the back here cousin
here's 500 bucks what the hell is 500
million to a guy worth 70 billion
nothing i'm not talking about that guy
i'm talking about guys that are still
building
building so a lot of times these these
guys that are running a company they
can't say nothing
because anything you say will be held
against you
because most of the people that are
working for you are not going to be the
ones that are agreeing with this policy
most of their employees are saying tax
the billionaire
tax the billionaire what they don't
realize is hey you keep saying tax the
billionaire
the billionaire is going to have to cut
some of his
employees let go of 20 of his employees
guess who pays the price you do because
the same person
queens business owners haunted by amazon
loss amid pandemic almost two years
after the amazon pulled out from a
proposal to build a massive headquarters
along queen's waterfront
the site is vacant vacant the same place
amazon's supposed to build and to many
locals the squandered economic
opportunities have a more painful
amid the coronavirus pandemic the site
just sits there empty it's terrible said
donna
dreamer owner of mad at llc art gallery
and gift store
we're in the middle of a pandemic people
say if we only had amazon
we got nothing the world's largest
e-retailer
abruptly cancelled his 25 000 job
producing campus
in february 2019 after being attacked
ferociously by aoc
and state senator mike gianaris so you
keep pushing me out i was gonna bring 25
000 jobs minimum
minimum at 150 000 of your salary you
push me oh now you want me back
so figure out who you guys want to bash
at this point well here's my question
for you
um and you made obviously a very
compelling argument here
um you know they've said if you're going
to become a billionaire you have had to
make thousands of thousands of thousands
of jobs
pop up out of nowhere right you've
created these jobs you're the job
creator right obviously look at
um jeff bezos like he could have brought
in
how much money how many jobs how much
salary into new york and now that's
evaporated that's gone
so it's so easy for someone that's
making
30 grand a year 40 grand a year
unemployed to be like tax the
billionaires
it's so easy for the bernies of the
world for the aocs of the world
to just scream tax the billionaires
because who's going to be like
who's going to be as impassioned as pbd
and say no these are the job creators
this is the reason that you have thing
here's the solution
here's the reason that if you do that
here are the ramifications it's just
so easy to scream tax the billionaire so
here's my question to you if you're new
york
if you're the bureaucrats in new york
and you're like look bro this is a
stupid idea
this is dumb we can't do this they're
going to leave cuomo is going to have to
cook them dinner what have you what have
you
on the flip side what's your solution to
that what's your solution if they if
they're if there's a
i want to find a way to get a billion
dollars for being poor
my goal is i sat down with one of our
guys this week
last week he's one of my employees he
sits with me
to tell me his vision of what dream he
has for what business he wants to build
you know what i did for 30 minutes with
the guy we sat and came out with a plan
for his dream to become a reality
he left fired up confused why is this
guy wanting my dreams i said why not
we're sitting there processing it
together with him right we're sitting
there talking to him
i have one goal i want you to stop
being poor and have your own money so
you can have a backbone
because the more savings you have the
more confidence you have the more
confidence you have
the better decisions you'll make that's
if you have strong character if you got
a bad character on the inside you
more money you get you're problematic to
the economy okay if you've got a
weak character here that's why you first
develop the character then you help that
person succeed in life right so what are
you doing in a situation like this
number one question how do we minimize
people being poor so how do you do it
for example if you make a hundred
thousand dollar your income
i make 50k to me what are you
double your salary no no how do i view
you you ever remember when you were
making
man think about when you were making 30
grand a year how did you look at
somebody that was making 70 grand a year
that bastard
no but how'd you look at him you can't
like do it i'd love to make 70 one day
right
imagine you're making 70. how did you
look at the guy making 150
oh brother let me tell you figures yeah
it's cool man i want to get to
you may so at what point does that
conversation not stop never never
never said that never but it's always
well he can afford it
well he can afford it well he can afford
it while he can afford it
well he can what do you mean he can
afford it
how can he afford it you can't afford it
i want to increase your number
so for me if new york focuses on
what do we need to do to get the bottom
and the middle
off to a good start where they can make
money get them back working
get them back generating get them back
rebuilding their confidence then things
are going to come back
up you don't sit there and say the
solution to this because
taxing the billionaires is another short
you know quick fix it's not going to be
basically saying that you want a
bottom-up approach not a top-down
approach is that essentially what it
comes down to
it's so easy to say trickle down take
the money and just sprinkle it down but
you're saying look let's grow these
people let's grow their mindset i get a
text last name
on one of my guys i get a text last name
from one of my guys i'm not gonna say
who it is but i'll just
read you what he says to me so this is a
guy that's a very capable guy and for
many many years i've been trying to see
if this guy's gonna get emotional or not
to want to do something big he's not
emotionally good or emotionally
emotional in a way but listen everybody
needs some kind of an enemy to want to
do something big don't get too emotional
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no
not emotional the way you do i'm not
talking about like crying by the
cubicles
because by the one i'm not talking about
by the way
[Laughter]
so he sends me a message i love it how i
won the bet i won
but i'm the one but wait a minute when
people win they cry sometimes
it was a good kind of good kind of
serious it was very impressive it was
very impressive
so i'm talking to this guy this guy's
all these lunches i'm trying to find an
enemy
i said the right enemy for you will make
you xyz money per year
he says one of my guys came up we're
brainstorming on who should be our enemy
i said what's that
he sends me a message i said you need a
true enemy
one that creates real emotion okay when
you generally have it like you know the
whole thing
we're talking about earlier this morning
with logan paul and mayweather and then
jake paul and all that stuff and jake
paul's calling out connor
and the only person jake paul follows on
instagram is conor's fiancee which is
very weird dirty movement oh that's
hilarious
yeah it's a hilarious yeah so so now you
but but that's a
fake hollywood yeah you give a good at
like mayorga de la hoya it's a
real enemy like how jordan would create
the enemy
if you got a real enemy good things will
happen so he finally says to me
pat i'm really getting sold out on my
best version my enemy has become a
negative media that perpetuates hate and
lies
to build uh to people to build division
lack of understanding when it comes down
to economic principles and laws morality
abortion i want to find ways to make
change in homelessness at an all-time
high being worse and worse
he's going through it so ask him a
question what kind of emotion does it
produce
he said fire purpose level of anger
frustration desire to protect
lead and teach god i spoke to the other
leaders
and i couldn't stop pat i couldn't stop
he texts me i got emotional about it i
can't help
this is not an emotional guy right okay
i want to get low income
and middle-income families to get
emotional
about their dreams and their purpose
it's such a basic fundamental thing that
we're talking about here
but if i get the bottom and the middle
excited about their dreams becoming a
reality
you'll be able to get rid of a lot of
these issues that we're dealing with
if you get middle and low income
families excited
about their dreams become a reality look
i've said this for the last
first time i started talking about this
in this method was march of 2008
one time i got on stage i was speaking
in front of 7000 people in las vegas and
i was given this message i'm 28 29 years
old and i'm talking exactly about
this language there's a difference
between a politician speaking a
nightmare language versus a dream
language
a dream language to me is mesmerizing
a dream language energizes people a
dream language gets me to want to
improve a dream language gets me to want
to get up and read a book
a dream language gets me to want to
figure out a way to get better like what
reagan used to talk yes i'm talking we
need and by the way
even obama talked to dreams when he was
giving his first speech
reagan talked dreams it's dreams we need
people dreaming again
and we're not doing that you don't just
say hey
here's what we got to do now let's dream
again yeah okay couple things
um you know cuomo's philosophy is tax
everyone he's even saying
taxes have to go higher in the middle
himself he totally is but i think we
give these politicians too much credit
right now i don't
especially in new york i don't think any
of them are thinking big picture like
you're saying
i think that's why i'm so ticked off and
annoyed because
they're trying to get to a one-class
system in this country the way it seems
and that's not about creating your
dreams and and making something of
yourself it's to be more dependent on
the government
and my problem with billionaires is the
perception of so many of them
who went so far over the top to try to
get a biden who i lump into it with the
rest of these new york politicians that
just want to tax everybody
you know make it you know make you more
reliant on the government so some of
these billionaires i know they can't
really say anything because they have
big businesses but the ones that talk
the most give you a bad perception
it's bad marketing about the billionaire
brand it's hard to root for them
because when they are so adamant about
trying to get biden
in and destroy a fellow billionaire
donald trump
it doesn't make sense it doesn't create
a lot of sympathy for them and it's hard
to understand
them i see what you're going i see what
you're saying you know
again this is new york we're talking
about let's let's focus on this a lot of
the billionaires you're talking about
are the
zuckerbergs of the world and the uh tim
cooks of the world and the silicon
valley
that that's not these billionaires a lot
of these hedge fund billionaire types i
assume
a lot uh did vote for trump especially
uh regarding corporate taxes so let's
not just like
billionaires they're all democrats i i
doubt that maybe the silicon valley has
type people
um so but i never said that i i said
what they're saying doesn't jive
with what their end game should be for
being that wealthy
well by the way just so you know
facebook is in a very dire situation
right now with biden's camp wanting them
to
separate the entire company up with
whatsapp and instagram all of them
so so break it up oh yeah i mean your
policies
got you the candidate that you got now
they have to break you up and
now guess what happens next what happens
now is hey
we can break you up if you don't listen
to us so you better
so now this is where the negotiation is
not just camp that's looking to break up
facebook i mean i don't know 46 state
attorney general i don't think i know
what i'm trying to do no no what i'm
saying to you yeah but didn't happen
no it's actively going on as we speak
it's yeah but it's been actively going
on for
a long time now with what these guys are
doing now
they're going to be able to break these
guys up but will they break them up
i will be very surprised if those guys
are broken up
very surprised if those guys are broken
up very if they're broken up
more power to you if they are well
something that i know that you're not a
fan of are
monopoly i'm not a fan of money here's
the other thing to consider so
it's how much does china want them to be
broken up because they're going to have
a say in it as well
yeah so look you we're talking about
this now we're talking about
florida wall street businesses and
fabulously wealthy money managers live
in new york to go to warmer climate a
smaller
tax bill hardly a new phenomenon it's
the first time uh industry heavyweights
have questioned new york's future as a
home of the big finance okay
i suspect florida will soon rival new
york as a financial
financial hub leon cooperman the hedge
fund manager who founded new york based
omega advisors told business and saturn
an email
tax and spend has been the northeast
policy
it has to change or new york jersey
connecticut will become
ghost towns okay ghost towns this is a
guy
that's from the industry talking about
there's going to be a ghost town up
there and then some other data
blackstone the world's largest private
equity firm headquartered on park avenue
manhattan is opening up an office in
miami with plans to bring 215 technology
focused jobs there from so-called back
office employees handling technology
systems from
miami then companies aren't just looking
they are signing
leases and preparing to physically move
employees in before the end of the year
to shave
dollars off their tax bill last year
florida dropped its corporate tax rate
from 5.5
to 4.458 beautiful thing to hear
in new york that rate is six and a half
percent in connecticut
where many hedge funds are based at
seven and a half percent despite
florida's low rate of 2019 investigation
by the orlando centennial found that 99
of all businesses
in the state pay no corporate income tax
at all say that last part again
99 of all businesses in the state pay no
corporate tax income tax at all
how do they get away with that 99 let me
tell you
if they do if they do yeah good for
florida
good for floyd you know who benefits
from that i'll be employees
those only won jobs okay if i was an
employee i wouldn't be complaining about
that too much
because those that money is going to get
to jobs
jobs creates what an income for people
when people make income who do they not
rely on the government
who wins the state of florida wins i 100
agree that those places could be pseudo
ghost towns
because right now if you do a cost or a
risk benefit analysis
you know what's what's the benefit of
staying
you can't even eat in a restaurant okay
and it's not like that's gonna change
anytime soon
if you have the wherewithal to say screw
it i'm moving either as an individual or
as a company
and there's a better situation there
they're gonna flock i mean this is real
i mean they are gonna blow out of there
out of the northeast
look the the the shutdowns they're not
gonna stop
they're just gonna find another reason
to not allow us to eat in restaurants or
something
i am 100 convinced of this okay but some
states have a different philosophy
and it's across the board watch a
football game the nfl should be so
grateful that the super bowl is in
florida this year
because look they're already having
about 20 000 fans per game for college
games for the tampa bay bucks
for the miami dolphins they're gonna be
able to probably put 40 or 50 000 people
in for the super bowl as opposed to if
it was in a different state that was
shut down
they'd have no fans whatsoever so i mean
it is two completely different
we are at a tipping point time in this
country
smart people are making decisions what
makes sense for the long term and
getting the hell out of the northeast
for a lot of people makes sense
so uh clearly this is a conversation
that's been going on for a long time in
florida
again again i live in miami this the new
yorker the
the new yorkers flooding miami is
nothing new obviously since covid
um people have said all right i can work
remotely now like what the hell am i
doing at this point
so my question to you is because
whatever's going on in new york is also
going on in california it's like yin
yang same thing
so at what point do you say all right
i'm moving from la you love la you live
there
you rail against the policies you rail
against living there you rail against
the taxes but my question is
at what point do you actually and i'm
not saying this disrespectfully
at what point do you put your money
where your mouth is then move it's when
you have an opportunity when you have a
reason to move you're not going to do it
just for this
just so you know tom and his family
would be ready to move anywhere if
there's an opportunity that comes up and
i'm more i'm more personifying what
someone would think
i'm not you're not specifically speaking
about i'm not saying tom
per se but i'm saying give me a glimpse
as you live in california you love it
there i've seen where you live manhattan
beach
you want to be there but there's like
you're like but you have you're thinking
about leaving at what point do you leave
though but are you asking yeah i'm
asking
it's for yourself but also put yourself
in i'm not going to move for the same
people because it'd be too hard of a
cell it'd be impossible i have kids you
know teenager
so that and my other my older daughter
lives there um so it would have to make
sense and then you go
done no-brainer what he just said is
most people
kids family uh habit
you're used to it i've been living there
i know the freeways i know it's weird
stuff like when i came to texas the most
annoying thing to me was
getting used to these exits and there's
roundabouts you know i think it's i
think it's harder to drive here than la
yeah i really do drive i'm not joking i
get lost here more than i ever got
another
i never got lost you have no hard how
clue how hard it is to uber around here
to get an uber yeah i don't know if
you're going left right but by the way
stay on this point yeah
and and give me some insight because
we've been talking about this for a
while but at what point you say
i screw it i am moving you're not seeing
it already i mean
you got to realize so there's a there's
a few different camps the following
camps
those who left a long time ago we're not
talking about those people let me go
through it for you
those who left a long time ago the
second camp is those who just left
the third camp is those who are prepared
are about to leave but no one knows
about it and there are those
who are in the tipping point about to
make a decision
don't think for a moment there isn't a
big community of people if i would have
told you larry ellison's moving to
california
moving to texas that's oracle oracle
yeah of course would you have said oh
yeah
uh h elon musk elon musk yes
and it's just these are these are the
billionaire the billionaire class yeah
they they have a lot of reasons to you
know i'm talking normal people
working people did i put my house on the
market the other day just two years ago
no joke i put my house on the market two
years ago
for one year was our on the market we
got
nothing no joke i put my house on the
market last week
24 hours two offers we gave them 20
12 more hours to make their final bid
till 12 o'clock they both came to a max
offer full price
and they said we're in one can we
everything just it's
so are you about to make an announcement
no no i'm not making any announcement
the announcement i'm trying to make you
is the fact that things
are moving so quickly that it's like the
real estate's like here
just go in yeah that's true if you're
sitting in arizona dude there's nothing
to rent today yeah
there's nothing to rent today i'll give
you another question so i i was running
a 14 bedroom house in lake tahoe
that's where we go for christmas we like
to go to lake tahoe okay
announcement lake tahoe shut down
heavenly shut down
ski slopes shut down everything's shut
down you can't party internally together
i call my guy i'm like dude what the
hell happened it says man i'm sorry
here they give the money back right it's
a fat check they give the money back
i call my brokers three of them we will
need a vacation rental home
call on every single place hey how about
this place no you don't want to go there
because they may shut down new york
how about this place you don't want to
go to colorado because they may shut
down how about this place no you may i
wouldn't go there
so then he says just look at the red
states the guy's a liberal
listen situation like this as a person
on the left just look at red states
what's a red state obviously florida is
not red is purple but it's a little bit
more conservative desantis is running it
he said your best bet is going to
florida for vacation during christmas
what a thing to say see these are behind
closed doors that people who are
spending money are realizing where money
is going
to people are making if i want to go to
vacation and i want to be by the beach i
want to be somewhere golf all that you
know what
it would have been arizona it would have
been at the palm springs not today
now it's the other direction very the
way people spend their money
is it tough to find a place out there
now where florida every house in palm
beach is sold out
wow rent everything is gone the guy's
like look
here's here's what the guy said to me
make an offer because this thing's
leaving i'm like yeah this is a sales
pitch
you know what happened we lost one of
them so the other realtor that called me
says pat
i'm telling you i'm like dude don't
worry about it here you go just take the
damn money
we need a place for the family because
you're competing against the world
essentially
so so what they're doing is they're
helping states like
florida texas washington hence the three
richest people in the world live where
two of them live in washington state no
taxes bezos and
uh gates and the other one just moved to
texas yeah
musk no state income taxes so these are
all going to places where they don't pay
state income tax you're going to start
feeling this very very quickly by the
way let me give a shout out to a couple
of people that are listening to this
if you enjoyed this last conversation
that myself
tom and adam had smash that subscribe
button if you enjoyed it i'm going to
give a shout out to a couple people we
got a bunch of 100
ones here okay we got one gene uh just
paid 99 just paid 100
just to say she paid 100 gene we love
you thank you so much appreciate the
love
uh we had the maxwell hernandez uh paid
a hundred dollars um
gave a hundred dollars saying tax on
wealthy people will not resolve anything
right history of the higher tax brackets
of the wealthy have not shown any
significant advancement aside from world
war ii era
of course as patrick has mentioned there
are adverse effects when done so
instead of higher tax bracket he said i
see it he said
where are the long-term fixes why not
motivate the wealthy to invest in
businesses to create more jobs and
government-sanctioned roi in different
sectors okay cool
as always keep up the good work uh
listening to uh
the podcast for years and valuetainment
has impacted me in a way of positively
personal awesome
and i got a couple other people let me
give them a shout out as well uh
we had one other person that said roger
alvarez who sat down with roy yesterday
grace sit down yesterday pad yes i
enjoyed i spoke to wife
yesterday and we're ready for florida
cheers awesome good for robert roger
alvarez
i had a good conversation with him proud
of him for making that big decision with
his family okay let's get back into it
let's get back into it so we got a few
other things to talk about
person of the year persons of the year
person of the year
joe biden kamala harris were you
celebrating when you saw that
i'm gonna shock you even though you know
obviously i was very emotional yesterday
breaking news biden is going to be the
president electoral college
officially put him in office but you
know what i'm going to shock you i do
not think that joe biden and kamala
harris
should be people of the year you know
these are where's the list you're not
people excuse me
persons over here person of the year
people is a bad word now
oh you got to be careful with people you
can't say people you say
person of the year persons please don't
offend our audience go go ahead
time persons of the year they were the
candidates persons
person people singular person even
though it's two
okay time knows better english than you
and i do so it's time set
person of the year for two people so
tell us
the four candidates or were uh biden and
kamala harris or biden
trump um the racial justice movement and
then frontline healthcare workers
coupled with anthony fauci i know we're
not about to say people or persons
in my opinion the winner should be
the frontline healthcare workers are you
freaking kidding me if
in a year of covid uh they're literally
giving up their lives
and and the death that they see on a
daily basis 300 000 deaths
in the united states over a million
deaths worldwide
the the healthcare workers uh should
win uh the person of the year people of
the year crew of the year whatever you
want to call them
they should be putting pictures of
doctors nurse nurses healthcare workers
on the cover of time not biden and
kamala harris not trump
not fouchy not social justice movement
the healthcare
workers time still has a magazine
congratulations that that's right up
time person of the year
is right up there with the good
housekeeping seal of approval
okay who gives a crap you're so
irrelevant time you suck
basically hey let's just look at this
she called him a racist
this year to his face a racist
he picks her because he has to this guy
can't even play with his poodle without
breaking half the bones in his body
okay the photo is horrible i mean what
is that even a photo
they look like they're dying both of
them it looks like you're at a funeral
for both of them
what a joke it's like it'd be like
playboy naming nancy pelosi
playmate of the year what did what did
joe biden do to you what did a democrat
do to you
something must have happened in your
life that was a strict commentary that's
all i'm just saying something must have
happened for you to get this angry about
something no man it's like time who are
you
you're irrelevant i mean they came out
with their shopping list the
shopping guide they they said go buy a
new walkman when they um
when they had trump in 2016 as time
person of the year what did you deserve
then
so you liked it then you defied history
you liked it the time was
back then it meant something forgot it
was four years ago it is
nice tom uh seriously time sucks who are
they
i think i think this happens every year
and this is exactly what they like
to do they like to pick somebody that's
gonna piss you off because it's gonna
bring more eyeballs and more people
talking about it and you
you know mark benhofe owns them now by
the way you know the the founder of
salesforce who owns time magazine
i don't know if you knew that yes he
bought him for like what did he buy if i
think he bought it for 351 million or
some number like that can you pull it up
mark benihoff buys time magazine benny
hoff
uh uh time magazine um
benny hoff time magazine let's see what
he paid for it
uh what did he pay for that's what i
want to know under 50 million probably
no no he paid he paid a good amount for
it uh 100
000 90 million that's nothing
ah that just pisses me off that's
nothing so
oh my gosh mark benny off let's just
give a shout out to him real quick
obviously
business person of the year
unquestionably was elon musk
well according to fortune magazine yeah
i think many people would
agree on that and then bezos richest man
in the world um
and i'm sure we'll touch on even gates
in the in this episode but mark benioff
salesforce he just
acquired slack kai probably has
something that he would want to add
about
i think he's was he called deal maker of
the year this guy's an absolute stud
this guy mark benioff
um kai what what did we talk about um no
he said he took over from larry ellison
on the most acquisitions
and acquired his work for larry ellison
yeah yeah
he was a former they just bought slack
yeah the guys he knows what's up
bennehoff yeah
yeah worked for uh ellison yeah i think
so at oracle
he was a vice president executive
of some sort he is not a household name
that just
tells you right there the power of who
you work for
let me tell you what that tells you
right that tells you the power of who
you work for
what what habits and things you pick up
from working for somebody like that of
course you think benihoff would have
been
if you hadn't had a person like that to
shadow what a great example of what it
means to shadow somebody
that's a beautiful story right there to
be able to work with someone like that
and plus it feels like he's competing
with them trying to outdo him but you
know what i disagree with one thing i
don't think time is that forward
thinking where they put them on the
cover
to engage i think they're that woke i
really do okay
yeah i mean to me i um i just kind of
see it i'm like yeah i guess they have
to announce those two as time magazine
person of the year i mean who else
you're going to announce realistically
who else
would have been the guy yeah would it be
they've done
in the past uh like in 20
uh they've done multiple people is what
i'm saying a couple years ago i think in
you know who was the time person of the
year you
not you pbd but us you the the people
the people were we were the time people
of the years like oh damn i'm a time
president
i might put that on my resume i was time
person of the year
2010 me and all seven billion of us on
this planet eight billion
but um 2016 was trump i
i kind of agree with tom that like who
gives a [ __ ] and i also agree
um it is important because people do
talk about this kind of stuff
and lastly i think they are looking to
stir up controversy when they put on a
bite in a common line but they did get
people
we're talking about it now if it was the
health care workers which i think
should have been the time people of the
year would be like if you're listening
to this who who do you think should have
been the time management obviously we
know our audience loves biden so
obviously they
have no idea what they're going to say
what do you think we have a naughty ass
who do you think should be
first of all no one's going to say
trump's the time end of the year i mean
it's yeah
if you're gonna say it's just the timing
there's gonna be a lot of people i'm
sure they're going to
what i'm trying to say is there's going
to be some that are going to say
something else
of our audience still thinks that agrees
with tom that trump is still going
through something that here's something
that's a little bit interesting pfizer
ceo 59 years old has not gotten his own
covet 19 vaccine because he does not
want to jump the line
what a noble thing to say ahead of uh
health workers and
nursing home patients this year albert
barola
says he hasn't gotten the shot he is
younger than the age group prioritized
to get the first
u.s and he's not a healthcare worker he
said the firm doesn't want to appear
executives can jump the line thoughts on
that
what was the ebola virus i think he'd
probably get it right we covered this
guy albert burla if you recall he's the
guy that did
a five million dollar stock exit
oh yeah three way before vaccine and you
were like five i was like five million
that's it i remember that interaction
that we had
um i think this is a nice pr move he's
had some very bad pr over the last
x amount of months you don't think it's
a big deal you think it's a it's clearly
if the guy wanted to get a freaking
uh vaccine he could have he could be
first in line he's the owner of pfizer i
mean what are we talking about here
you know but he's saying look you know
i'm gonna wait it's it's a pr move
and and we're talking about him and
again if he
did or didn't do the shot and didn't say
anything we wouldn't be talking about
him
but more importantly there is a vaccine
now
right we yeah it happened in the uk yes
now we have uh
yes in in new york the first person to
receive the vaccine
so when do you guys get in your shot you
know here's my opinion on the ceo number
one i bet he didn't want to answer that
question
but he was forced to someone asked him i
don't think he put that out on a press
release
they backed him into a corner he had to
answer the question number two if that
was the case
he should have said i'm planning on
getting it very soon to maybe exude a
little bit more confidence in your
product
because when the ceo says i haven't
taken it yet i don't want to jump the
line whatever
it makes me think man do you have some
suspicions about your own product
so his his his first scenario was never
to talk about it but since he had to he
should have said yeah i'm going to a
week from wednesday or something
it is kind of weird for the guy to say i
don't trust my own product you know
if you if you're the ceo of lexus i
expect your garage to have a lexus there
i'm telling if you're the ceo of ford
you better have a couple fords in the
garage
if you're the ceo of pfizer pitching
kova 19 vaccine i'm expecting to say
dude i took it you're fine you can take
it you know that's it
you know what i would do tomorrow if i
was the moderna publicist
or a pr director say come out and say
i'm taking it first i believe in mine
you know because by the way he's
armenian time magazine of the year we
had a few people that said trump we had
frontline workers health workers doctors
uh some people said george floyd uh um
elon musk elon musk is all over the
place with uh
uh uh some said joe rogan
uh george floyd elon musk it's like
literally ten names
i see a lot of xi jinping xi jinping
i think that could have been one uh uh
um let's see what else we got yeah she
by the way xi jinping is
everywhere maybe it's the same guy that
keeps saying it about yeah it's the same
guy that
nancy pelosi time magazine
uh woman of the year is who would have
been so okay so now let's talk about how
many of these
how these companies are handling the
shutdown with uh google okay
you guys know obviously google had a
little bit of an outage yesterday right
30 minutes to an hour was out
google and youtube and apparently amazon
had it as well the week prior to that
uh what are your thoughts about a
company this big having an outage a
google
having an outage for 30 minutes do you
have an opinion on that i do i think
it's unacceptable
i mean i i cannot believe i mean would
you think one thing about these tech
companies is they don't have outages
i mean that's something that your local
you know your local internet provider
has you know your cable company goes
down for a little bit or something like
that
not google and it makes me just think
you know this is becoming a little bit
more didn't youtube have something a few
weeks ago as well
and and i bring it back to the fact that
these tech companies are so
quick to have everybody work from home
no one has to come back to the office
uh i believe that there's got to be some
sort of
correlation between the fact that they
don't have the engineers in-house
they don't have everybody you know under
the same roof and you're having these
issues
i mean when you look at these corporate
campuses for these tech companies it's
staggering how big they are
i mean we're talking about what 45 acres
for one of them yeah you know millions
literally millions of square feet of
office space and then you think what
apple okay so apple just has that
circular new thing it's like four
stories tall
seven million square feet of office
space and it cost them a little bit over
a billion
and you're thinking that's nothing to
these companies so they
there must be something about them not
wanting to have
everybody in the office there must be
some huge savings because
you know what's a billion bucks to them
that's nothing you know that's security
for
sergey brin for one year probably or
something like that you know it really
is minimal
in the grand scheme but i really think
and they're so quick to say hey you
don't have to come back to work until
the middle of 2021 or
twitter saying you don't ever have to
come back to the office how is that a
good thing
you know the guy who is the exception to
that is reed hastings he says there's
nothing positive
about us not being in the office
together i want them all back as soon as
possible
his alternative is four days at the
office one day flex where maybe you work
at home which i think that makes a
little bit more sense
you've people are gonna start going nuts
if they're just gonna be working from
home forever i know so many people
trapped working at home in l.a in
california they feel different to me
i think they're going a little stir
crazy it's crazy you're not as active
you don't have the social interaction
it's a very negative thing for the
country a couple things
uh i don't know what what happened with
the how long was the shutdown a half
hour
yeah i think it was 30 minutes 30
minutes first thing that came to mind
maybe because i was reading that
treasury story is
hackers you know modern day warfare
are aren't going to be hot wars aren't
going to be
you know that's why i think you know not
to get all political like the whole
building the wall thing is so
archaic like today it's you know
um bio warfare hacking
software viruses what have you so
who hacked something is is where i'm
going i think so
you know what it also you know the song
i'm only human
you know that song they did in in this
auto insurance commercial i don't know
if you've seen it
yet the guy keeps hitting stuff and you
know
mistakes yeah it's a great auto
insurance company
who is that no it's like human league
yeah so i'm only human
born to make mistakes right so is google
allowed to make mistakes i mean that's
the part can you imagine like google's
down we're furious
i cannot believe this free service is
down what is wrong with you guys you
guys better get it back
up it's free damn it you know we ain't
paying for it right it's not uh
you think that's a human mistake all of
the internet
all i'm saying is what google does is
it gives smaller business owners the
ability to realize that even a
juggernaut like a google makes mistakes
right
even a juggernaut like google can make
mistakes like that but i do like what
you said about the fact that when people
are now working from an office maybe
they're not as
focused as they would have been working
from home by the way here's here's how
it's working out for all these guys on
how they're doing their
uh what do you call it their uh uh or
their remote work yeah let me take a
look at which ones i got here so
uh facebook is uh asking people to work
remotely until june 2021 so they're
gonna go another six months
apple uh said that they're not in a
hurry to return at least not for
several months working from home in 2021
amazon until june some of them some of
them obviously have to work
from work twitter is like listen you can
work from home for the rest of your life
if you want
salesforce is saying you got to return
to work august of 2021
slack is saying remotely on a permanent
basis if they'd like uh and they're also
saying june
microsoft will reportedly allow 150 000
workers to work from home
at least part-time this is like a hybrid
model reid hastings is saying uh they
won't open up most unless if people
are majority of the people are
vaccinated interesting so hastings said
he hasn't seen an upset or remote work
uh no i don't see any positive not being
able to get to get in person
particularly internationally is a pure
negative i've been super impressed
at people's sacrifices meaning he wants
people to work
from the office stripe is uh saying uh
one time one part one-time bonuses
they're also kind of following the
norm on what's taking place i don't know
i don't know about this working from
home situation here let me give you a
little perspective here and
and i and i i shout out to kai for
putting together all these lists of
companies but let me tell you some of
the words that stuck out to me and then
i'll give you my opinion
here's some of the words that we're
using now when it comes to future of
work that did not exist
a year ago you know remote has been a
thing but wfh i remember what the hell
is wfh work from home
hybrid model flexible schedule virtual
work decentralized jobs
a collaboration day like where you're
working from
uh working remotely for the uh you know
four days a week for example and then
one day a week you come in for a
collaboration yeah collaboration day a
relocation bonus where if you're gonna
move
they might pay you less but they'll give
you a twenty thousand dollar relocation
pose
a bonus now we're talking we had a
conversation a couple weeks ago about
your employer might um
have the ability to make sure mandate
that you are vaccinated
but just to put it in perspective here's
a more of a macro historical
uh perspective when it comes to work so
let's talk about work life balance for a
second because i think no matter what
you do for a living
everyone strives to have a better
work-life balance if all you're doing is
working
right then your personal life suffers
and if all you're doing is kind of
chilling and
doing what a lot of people down in south
beach do and just kind of like
you know work on their tent and they're
not necessarily working and this is the
problem with
talent new york versus you know miami
per se you're not exactly going to be
getting ahead and
so just painting a picture overall of
work for
thousands of thousands of years people
worked from home
right that was their thing whether you
were a farmer or a blacksmith or you
were a tradesman
you had your uh you know farm outside
your house
and you were you lived upstairs and that
was just sort of what you did but
since the industrial revolution you know
i'll call it 150 years ago per se
people have started to show up to the
workplace right go to the companies to
the factories
you know leaving the house it's almost
like you had a double life it's like you
would kiss
you know we've all seen the you know the
leave it to beaver type shows
or you'd kiss your kids goodbye in the
50s all right i'm gonna go
to work this is sort of a mad men ask
type of picture of this
but you go to work you you leave you're
out the house by eight you're back home
by six o'clock what have you
you have your work life and then you
have your home life
so what i what i like about this is now
maybe there's going to be a better
work-life balance maybe you're working
from home
you know three days a week two days a
week you're working from the office one
or two days a week i think
all in all what this is going to enable
people to do if they can
do this not everyone's going to be able
to do this it's just have a healthier
work-life balance so it'll be
interesting how it plays out to have a
more of a blended
uh happier life you know what what's up
with all this corporate space
i mean that is a lot of office space not
being used you got the companies leaving
california
you got the companies that say you don't
even have to come into the office if you
thought i mean
that's a lot i i don't get it what is
the end game with these companies
you know it's just i don't like it i'm
not a fan of it and i think
um i think you know if you've studied
this over the
course of a year or two it's gonna you
know production's gonna go way down you
know what we are not talking about with
somebody just give five bucks a talk but
i'm gonna give a shout out to lorenzo j
i do agree with them
he said pat you and so boy of the year
have not spoken about tony shea
and his passing it's been reported that
covet depression played a role in his
death
right covert depression is playing a
role
uh uh in his death okay and cnbc i think
cnbc or msnbc i sent you to link high we
have talked about
internally but not here though not here
though if you want to bring that up just
kai just cr like writing a paragraph
buddy okay there you go okay
tony cnbc press uh control minus minus a
couple times
control control okay there you go bring
it down a little bit uh no no the other
way yeah the other way tony shay's last
month's
uh are tragic reminder how coveted
isolation can worsen mental health
here's how to help so
here's a guy that's in isolation he
likes to be around people
okay and there's a lot of weird stories
that came out
about you know i immediately said rest
in peace because i remember reading this
book
of deliverance happiness ridiculous book
i made it a book of the month everybody
to read because there's a lot of value
in it
see that's worth a half a billion
dollars it's crazy no will
no will no will yeah yeah this this
guy's worth a half a billion dollars no
will
drink isolated drank a lot try different
drugs
okay yeah i i wanted to see where you
were going with this because
tragic number one but being isolated
because of covid was not the cause of
his death
this guy was doing some weird [ __ ] man
but wait a minute let me ask you a
question i mean you're going to
being isolated is not the cause of death
you don't think people are having
suicidal this
you know conversations what i said i'm
talking about him specifically but let
me ask you a question
yes here's a question for you here's a
question for you how many people
you ever seen that one movie where
there's i wish i could know what a movie
it is some of you guys may remember what
movie it is
this guy who this girl who comes to work
every day she's suicidal
every day she's suicidal she comes to
work
and she goes and does her thing doesn't
talk to anybody and then one day
somebody says oh your hair looks so good
today
her level of susa you know it went lower
it's a movie i can't remember the movie
she would go to work and she was ready
to kill herself and she was just like so
sick of life and all this other stuff
dude sometimes coming to work and you're
around people you're like hey what's up
johnny what's up bobby how you doing
how's everything
right take that away from people to not
have interaction with human we need
interaction
dude you're talking about you want to
increase my immunity
okay put me around some people a little
bit for me to be able to talk to people
what about that anxiety that depression
that also goes in effect
i love that point and and i'll i'll give
you kudos to that and then i'll get back
to tony shea i think aristotle once said
we are
social animals we are social like people
need
to be interacting with other humans
that's just a
basis of life i mean shout out to what
we do here every day
i spoke to my buddy who's a huge like
the biggest trump supporter ever he's
out in uh pittsburgh
shout out to scumbag joe he was shocked
shocked that we come to an office and
work he's like you guys
go to work every day why envious yeah
well i mean he's
yeah maybe um he's still getting over
the fact that
that trump hasn't won but he was shocked
he's like you hold on what i was
facetiming with him yesterday
but he's uh he can't believe we're going
to work
in texas it's very normal yes and red
states
but uh florida as well yeah i got to
tell you guys going back and forth
it's just like entering two different
universes from texas to california
really
it totally is but with tony shea yeah
and everything you talked about being so
social interacting having to be like hey
your hair looks nice
pat you're putting your hair doesn't
look as curly today it looks nice you
know like
getting compliments hey what's up cool
fast sick best tom
like people crave that need that need
appreciation need recognition no doubt
so
covet has had some effects especially on
businesses no doubt no doubt no doubt
with tony specifically and i'm a fan of
his even jeff bezos
who doesn't post a lot on instagram i
don't know if you follow bezos on
instagram
he posted a picture of tony shea like
respect yeah but he was doing some weird
stuff he got down to i think a hundred
pounds
he was seeing how long he could go
without eating or urinating well adam
did you see he has this diet where it
was called the alphabet diet where one
day you only eat foods that start with
an a
the next day it's only b but they
literally said when you got down to wxyz
he wasn't eating at all
crazy that he lost six yeah food with
the next but the the
the saddest thing here and he was doing
all this weird stuff
he was sort of a pyromaniac he had a
fascination with fire he was playing
with fire
he barricaded himself in a house the
house caught on fire choked on smoke
whatever
happened happened but extreme example
um versus what actual normal people
don't give isolation any credit to that
you don't give isolation five percent
credit to push them over the edge that's
not what i said
i'm saying isolation is a real thing you
talked about how people are social
creatures
and aristotle you know said that we are
social animals and we need to interact
yeah but that doesn't mean that you go
down to a hundred pounds you do an
alphabet diet and you get
become a pirate are you asking for me to
do an endorsement of alphabet diet
because we're not doing it
is this another one of those shout outs
looking for sponsors no no we're not
doing alphabet diets not on
valuetainment no
no no i'm not i'm not disagreeing with
you but by the way he's saying he was
doing some weird even in the book
delivering happiness he talks about the
kind of parties he put together he's
just a party guy he likes the party he
has
a lot of drugs enablers all around him
too no one that could tell him to stop
sure but the biggest thing and you might
want to weigh in on this
he recently uh well he sold his company
to amazon
however many years ago for a billion
dollars but he recently stepped down as
the ceo of
zappos he had all this money money can't
buy happiness it was fun
maybe sort of lost his purpose he was
exploring with life and the meaning of
life and kind of going down a wrong path
um and you know he sort of lost his baby
i don't i don't know bro i think you
know you need uh
yesterday we got some bad news okay and
i'm going to say publicly so everybody
hears this i don't have to say
you know uh uh uh to a bunch of
different places so
uh uh two weeks ago we announced we're
having two ends thanksgiving we
announced we're having two ones we went
to the doctor doctors like we have to
see you guys asap yesterday we want to
do the ultrasound one of the babies is
dead
right shut up you have one baby is uh
what's body was right there in the
ultrasound the other baby you see
uh fully grown the baby died like
exactly when we announced that
thanksgiving the baby died okay so
babies stay same size the other one has
grown okay
so you know i'm saying this i'm not
saying this you know but what i'm trying
to tell you is this
we go to the doctor yesterday we come
back here jennifer comes
she's in her office morale goes talks to
her
there's a relationship there's somebody
that you have somebody to talk to
i am grateful for the people were around
because you have someone to say
dude i just had a bad day today dude
things are not going right oh good man
it's all gonna be fine
and the spirit around you can lift you
up
what do you what do you do so for us
believe me listen it's been a very weird
week for us it's not been the easiest
week for us it's been a little bit weird
because a lot of things are going on
in and uh uh you know i've been
talking to jen as we're going through
this how about the people that have
things like that happen that have no one
to talk to to go sit there and you know
just how you doing man
you want to go have lunch you want to go
have coffee you want to take a walk are
you okay
are you good did even somebody ask you
are you okay is everything all right
yeah i'm good
that release of man to man women to
women
face to face it is liberating
you need it people need it so many of
them don't have it
you have to have somebody to talk to and
that zoom is not giving you the personal
touch by the way
zoom is not the personal time zoom is
great technology you know
it's changed obviously he became the of
the year the person business person of
the year
with time magazine for what he did with
uh uh i think he was the guy that became
the business person of the year
for uh starting for doing what he did
with zoom but people need the personal
touch
and i feel a guy like tony shay just
needed somebody to tell him bro you got
to slow your roll and you just sometimes
need to hear that over
and over and over and over again until
somebody says at the right when you say
you know what
that was soothing that was comforting
you're comfortable with it right
so yeah look um i feel bad for people
that are fully isolated away from
everybody yeah
well condolences man yeah i i appreciate
it jen for sure
really sorry to hear that i you know uh
the the new normal this is becoming a
new normal who defines that this is
normal
you know i look at you know i think
people are going to grow to hate zoom i
i think people are going to go
to think of zoom as a negative school
my kids have been on the zoom school for
nine months so it's going to be a year
in march and there's no hope for them
going back to school
and it's just it's so unhealthy i mean
you've literally given up a year of your
life
i mean and there's no end in sight it's
it's it's depressing
it's terrible have you ever seen how
single babies babies who are
one one child family how different they
are than those who have a sibling
you ever you ever studied you ever
noticed the trend with people that are
by themselves
yeah by themselves well look at the guy
like robin williams it's very famous
only child says you know it's a little
bit like man think about being the only
child it's not
the you know like when we when we i
intentionally when we bought a dog i
bought two of them you got two cats
you got two pit bulls right i don't know
about getting one dog
you know it's like the guy needs company
you know you know your siblings i don't
know about one child it's tough and by
the way some people make a decision to
do that and some of them can't do it so
not judging anybody that your help is
not alive some people are just glad and
thankful that they just had one
but look that whole one child you know
story is
you know the kid can only tell mom and
dad you can't relate to
he has to have somebody on a daily basis
to relate to a kid somebody at least
that's
two three four five years his age where
there's some kind of non-isolation
you're working from home all by yourself
bro i don't know
i don't know if this is i don't know if
we know the side effects of this long
term that's all i'm saying
we're holding a meeting right and my
guys are saying well what do we do with
this there's a meeting i'm supposed to
be in san antonio this weekend the
conversation was
they're doing it at this place a real
nice place like tahoe
beautiful home we did an event two years
ago they had it locked and everything
was set up
and then they get the notice i'm
supposed to be in lake tahoe this friday
for an event and i'm supposed to be in
lake town next week for christmas
should we get the award this week for
lake tahoe okay what do we do
i said people need to be around people
figure out a way to go to a state
that allows you to be around other
people yeah follow the six feet the
whole nine
so guess what state they're doing their
event in texas guess what city san
antonio
hotel founded opened it up great they're
going to follow the guidelines they'll
be in the same room together because
people need
company and i'm doing a kickoff meeting
beginning of the year january i think a
sunday monday kickoff meeting right
after new year's i'm holding a kickoff
meeting
i've been doing this for a long time
this year we're doing it live here
in texas dallas at a hotel we're going
to follow the six feet guideline
but we're doing it because people need
to be around other
people i think that shows leadership for
these companies that say hey
you know what here's the last thing i'll
say you look at california which is shut
down everything new york which is on the
verge of shutdown
everything it's not working it's not
like that is resulting in these numbers
radically going down so you look at this
objectively and you're saying okay
they're putting all these harsh
restrictions on you
you can't interact you can't go to work
you can't go to school you can't go to
church
and yet it's not moving the needle one
bit
well your kids are all in school right
now they are
yes they're on school now uh two of them
were not
they had to shut it down for a couple
weeks but now they're all going to
school
yeah but the high school at the school
is shut down still fully yeah the high
school
high school so the younger the kids the
younger kids a little bit more these
kids need to be around other kids i mean
imagine dude
i can't even tell you like i remember
when my son was like
60 days into it he's at home isolation
it's like he was a loser one day i mean
he was like completely losing them one
day
tico he was like man i gotta be what's
going on daddy what do we do wrong cause
a daddy you didn't do anything wrong
this regulation i want you to be around
your friends so i was
they were coming to the office they were
happy to see you guys they were coming
here like oh what's up you know walking
around just like seeing human beings oh
there are people out there
that kind of but not a lot of people can
do that you can bring your kids to work
yeah not a lot of people you compound it
but there's no other releases you can't
go to the park you can't work out you
can't go to the gym
you can't play in your organized sports
leagues it's terrible
um yeah my i have a nephew he's
uh nine years old and my sis my sister
my sister's son that's
like my little best friend they've only
had one kid and i
make a point to make sure that i'm
hanging out with that guy i'm bringing
him around all of my best friend's kids
like listen you got to interact here
yeah because i saw that he was becoming
a little like
that's my stuff don't touch it i'm like
listen buddy like i'll house all your
[ __ ] i don't i don't think
like we're not playing that game we're
not playing the selfish kid game you're
going to learn how to share
you're going to learn how to lose
properly you know like i'm not going to
let you win
only child syndrome is a real thing and
you got to teach them i'm gonna give the
complete opposite somebody just gave
five bucks and they said my son is an
only child but he loves the online
school for the flexibility
and now he spends more time with his
friends there are some stories like that
you know to be complete opposite of what
we're talking about
and then nova terry just gave 10 bucks
and i have an online business i chill
and work from home
all the time barely have friends haven't
been outside in literally months i'm one
of the crazy
few who can live like this hahaha there
are people that can live like introverts
there are people that can live like that
you know pat i think
adam could be a good dad that was
seriously i think i think
adam adam is i think get to work i think
adam will make a wonderful dad adam will
make a wonderful dad but you know
when it comes down to marriage man you
you fall in love emotionally but you got
to marry logically
to marry logically it's a
very it's my biggest problem yeah i know
you want to get married
very emotional there's no logic going in
dating the wrong women well listen if
you're looking on tinder you're going to
just constantly fall in love emotionally
it's just a bunch of emotions
bro oh it's not it's only fantastic
that's what you told me yesterday
why don't you tell us about the only fan
store you brought up yesterday oh no do
i mean just in general or i mean
gamification you were like third highest
scorer with the most money spent on only
i said
holification i'd like to see if our uh
audience has any thoughts on
on only fans i'd love to hear in the
comments section so one of the
businesses that has definitely
blown up since the pandemic is only fans
now what is only fans it's basically
this
paywall on the internet you know about
this you're looking at me like what's
going on no i do know um yeah
um all the the women out there for the
most part there's men that do this i
assume as well
um uh women out there and
specifically i'm talking about the porn
stars the
uh strippers the dancers the cocktail
waitresses
you know a lot of you know prettier
women who
were workers ladies of the night that no
longer could go to work how did they
make their money
they went on to only fans and basically
there's a lot of
women um emma what's the girl's name
pellethorn bella thorne
she made a million bucks in like 20
minutes or something like that
yeah something ridiculous in a day
basically people pay
you know peep show peep show exactly
exclusive content exactly exclusive
content
it's a what have you what have you what
have you so you know you know think
about it you go on instagram and you
just gotta build followers and hope
advertisers send you money or something
or send you
uh swag so you're good with this oh i
think it's brilliant i mean it's
capitalism at its finest and you know
what people are used to that
you know that subscription model for
everything they do and i don't think you
think of six or seven bucks is a big
deal anymore the problem that i'm
that i'm seeing with this only fans
thing and look i get it capitalism make
your money
is okay i get the strippers and the
dancers and you know
the porn stars and you know the girls
who were like
you know cocktail waitresses at a strip
club but they weren't really stripping
whatever again like
the instagram model i get those girls
like they're gonna go
naturally go on to this uh website only
fans would you ever have
did you ever no no no would you have
did you ever strip i never had the abs
for it man no but
let's just say if you had the
opportunity would you have no it's not
why not
he was born what about but i'm asking
you what about you
so i'm asking you a question would you
have stripped if they paid you good
money
no i i just i think that's never that's
never i think
tom tom's just blowing my mind
they pay you good money all the way
strip or just like a chippendale thing
reiki never never would you have
you know what maybe i'm thinking about
it first of all [ __ ] it let's do it
19 years old gosh yeah that's got crazy
here's my point with the only fans
thinking about it so you you would be an
only fan actually
it's the girls that graduated college
they didn't have a job they have a
degree
it's girls who just had normal jobs they
got laid off they were just normal
waitresses cocktail waitresses
whatever now they're doing it now here's
the thing
you're never gonna make us talk about a
brand like only fans
this is where you get sponsorships yeah
why didn't you go to only fans since
you're such a diehard fan of them to say
i endorse only fans my name is never
signed up i just know that
there's a lot of girls that i i know
that are doing it um
[Music]
it is what it is it is a lot of people
are realizing that
learning a lot about you said there's
nothing about that part that's soy boy i
mean think about they have nothing to
lose by doing this and they throw a
little bit
that's not true there is something i
mean we saw the story in the new york
post about like an emp
lady a nurse in new york she was
you know doing some only fans listen if
you're doing only fans you're doing some
risque stuff online yeah
new york post called her out and so
there's women that
have normal jobs you know by day that
want to make some extra side hustle
money
but they get called out for doing some
what i call a job i think this is a
perfect transition into our sponsors
today
if you're ever on your ipad or your
phone and you're visiting only fans and
you're using wi-fi you got to make sure
others cannot see what sites you're
visiting
yes or no yes this is one of the reasons
why we support
and endorse expressvpn it's very easy to
use you have it on your iphone you have
it on your ipad you have it on your
computer
you're literally logged on you're doing
what you're doing but if you're using
someone's wifi at yard house at
starbucks
nobody can see what searches you're
doing that includes if you're going out
only fans like adam
yes so one thing about only one thing
about the uh expressvpn and i'm being
serious with you guys i actually use
this product it's on my phone it's on my
pc it's on my ipad
i use it regularly it doesn't matter
whether you use comcast verizon a tnt
any that stuff it reroutes your internet
connection through their secure server
so
your isp can't see the sites you visit
keeps all your information secure by
encrypting 100 of your data with the
most powerful encryption available
most of the time i don't even realize
they're there it's available on
everything
including a smart tv protect your online
activity today with the vpn rated number
one by cnet and wired once again number
one by cnet and wired
visit my exclusive link expressvpn.com
forward slash
vpn once again expressvpn.com forward
slash
pbd vpn sign up for a year you'll get
three months free with express
vpn dot com forward slash pbd
vpn that would only happen if you would
have talked about only fans yeah good
segue that that's that that would have
only happened
i'm setting you up for success here
shout out to expressvpn i can go on only
fans anytime i want without anybody
worrying about uh
where now when you use expressvpn and
you're on pornhub do they see it or not
they actually don't say they don't no i
wanted to make sure because it's very
important for someone
okay so so so russian hackers so russian
hackers let's talk about russian hackers
speaking of hackers and porn and only
fans pat is killing it with this yeah
so russian hackers suspected of spying
on u.s government including treasury and
commerce department
russian hacking is likely to become one
of the top intelligence priorities of
the
by the administration okay suspected
russian hackers have infiltrated
several key parts of the u.s government
including the treasury we know that the
security breaches were so alarming that
they promoted prompted the national
security council to meet saturday
reuters reported and come less than a
week from um
less than a week after a national
security agency warned that the russian
state-sponsored actors
were exploiting weak spots in the
computer system used by
u.s federal agencies u.s federal
agencies and minister ministers
uh including treasurer comes on
smackdown got it this is much bigger
story than
one single agency a source femalers
familiar to with the story told reuters
this is a huge cyber espionage campaign
targeting the u.s
government and its interests thoughts
worst case scenario i i don't think
there's any way to minimize just how
terrible and serious this is i mean when
you look at i mean they've been
inside their system since march all
right cover and these are the best
hackers in the world
okay so solarwinds you're saying why
them well because look at their clients
most of america's fortune 500 companies
top 10
u.s telecommunications providers all
five
branches of the us military the state
department national security agency in
the office of the president of the
united states
while we are off worrying about
ourselves and bickering amongst each
other between
republicans democrats and thinking
china's our only enemy russia's sitting
back there
very sly very savvy very smart
looking to destroy us just like some of
these other other countries are
this is huge i would love to know what
they got i i hope we
a retaliate against russia okay if it's
russians that did this we have to
retaliate in some way they
now look i think we probably have better
hackers i mean what we could be doing to
other countries
or we might have some silent threats
that we could shut down your grid in
five seconds or do whatever
i would imagine that and eric you
probably know some of the the tactics of
our
military cyber teams but i'm sure we're
top top shelf
um and i also think this company in
austin texas
needs to have some repercussions solar
winds do you not have anything in place
where you can't tell that half of the
kremlin is inside your system
i mean my god this is horrible and you
know the treasury i mean when you just
think of some of these places that
they've infiltrated it's bad news
yeah the the this is a major worry i
mean we talked about last
week about who's the number one threat
the united states is for sure it's china
no doubt
um economically for sure when it comes
to cyber
look russia don't don't play um and tom
brought up a good point here we are
arguing amongst ourselves the proud boys
versus antifa on the left versus the
right and
trump versus biden but let's not forget
we're all american here and we have
countries
around the world who are definitely um
rooting against the decline of america
and put russia at the top of that list
and put vladimir vladimir putin
right at the top of the top of the list
with xi jinping right you can put iran
on that list north korean that's less
these hackers don't play and i'd like to
see this is what i talked about earlier
on the show
modern warfare right it's cyber it's bio
warfare
it ain't hot wars anymore um
you're giving me a little smirk what's
the smirk do you remember a couple
episodes ago i said watch how close how
how the left and biden pitch who the
next enemy is
and i told you it's going to be russia
what did i tell you
and the attention is going to get away
from you don't remember me saying this i
do when did i say this okay no no you
said this
last episode when did i say this two
weeks ago okay go ahead kai
uh what if what if this is a chinese
hack making it look like
a russian yeah so for me it's so easy to
blame everything on russia the old
chinese hackers blame it on russia is
that old
guys it is so easy to blame everything
on russia russia's such an easy target
to hate
putin's so much easier to hate than
china so much easier to hate in china
so look i'm not saying read into it all
i'm saying is i'm not getting emotional
about the story
here's what i do know guess who's
hacking into our system
they all are everybody is yes but who
you pitch as the biggest enemy
everybody's hacking you think china's
not hacking into our system are you
kidding me the insiders they have
did you hear about that sex spy that
they have the the lady that you
you read about that right the i think
you even wrote about that right
on vtpos.com yes there's a sex by
chinese
sex spy you want to tell us about well
hanging out with
eric swalwell but you know yes that's
something different so literally and
she's not the only one they think
there's
hundreds that china has sent in here and
it's a brilliant move
they get these uh charismatic beautiful
people that are essentially working for
the the communist party in china
and they send them over here and they
and they infiltrate it they get close to
these politicians they're having a
sexual relationship
they're getting all kinds of dirt
they're probably they're probably
getting access to their computer i mean
you could see how vulnerable these
politicians very effective
yeah i got to make a phone call there's
an
asian lady i've been uh talking too
lately well you can get away with it
because she's on only fans but you know
the whole thing here with uh uh this is
a very similar story of red sparrow
yeah okay red sparrow if you've seen the
movie i don't know if you've seen a
movie
enlighten us pat you've never seen a
movie the book have you read the book
it sounds like have you got you guys
know the story red sparrow is exactly
what china's now doing that russia used
to do
beautiful russian women who were fully
trained they would come in and they
would go and get into the most powerful
politician's bed and
hey then negotiation is very easy we
have tape we have this we have that if
you don't want it to come out you better
give us this
it's a very very very effective method
because
man's weakness is through his zipper
if you can get in there and get some
videotape and negotiate that through
you know by the way one of the best guys
are doing that is apparently borat
because he knows how to go and get some
other guys and get him to get him on
tape
it's not a hard method to do shout out
to really i had an instruction
did i tell you the insurance story about
this one guy that they were fighting for
35 million dollar policy what the other
guy did did i tell you this story or no
yeah i talked about it yeah i think i
don't talk about it anyway rings a bell
this isn't all you're dropping
this is a method that's been going on
i'm just curious to know who they're
going to pitch as the big
enemy will it be russia for us to be
scared well i know yeah
would russia take offense if they're
being blamed for no reason
to say it's not looking like i i think
putin minds yeah
i probably do i think putin's the kind
that's like listen
keep you know keep building me up as a
big random it's okay scare the hell out
of everybody with
two things yeah it very well may be
russia if they're coming out and saying
it so let's just not pin this on china
but one thing i know for sure pat we're
not gonna give china a pass on this show
right here
we're gonna hold china accountable so so
even though biden may
even though our friend hunter biden may
even though the
uh left-leaning democrats
what is it with you protecting maybe out
there's this russian china red sparrow
that i'm talking to
that has infiltrated my mind why are you
and my zipper why are you so protective
of china i'm not perspective of china
honestly open it up right now stop it
listen i don't want you to be isolated
by yourself we've got friends here tell
us why do you love china so much
yeah i just i don't have an answer to
that i do not love china what do you
think it is kai with adam's uh
infatuation with china he's got to be on
the payroll
if china wants to pay me he's like
hollywood china tried to pay you a
million bucks
paying attention to a thousand dollars
china tried to pay pat
600 to come give a speech well they're
going to give you 300 and they were
going to dedicate 300 in your honor or
something you didn't see the email
so we got on the call were you on the
call when did we talk china yeah i think
i was there
you were on the call so they they gave
me 600 000
is what they wanted to fly you to china
i fly to china
and i hold the check of 300 000 to give
to their charity of
choice their charity of choice their
charity of choice
so but i keep 300 of it and i give 300
to them
which by the way i've never heard of
anything like that in my life but
they have you as a propaganda tool i
mean it's basically i mean you
know the playbook exactly but it works
in hollywood i mean
didn't jack the founder of alibaba he
owns half of hollywood i mean although
he owns half the studio
crow pay for play look at the nba but
you know what here's the thing about
china not to change the subject too much
but they've had this game plan and they
stick with it i mean they came up with
this game plan decades ago
and we're playing right into their hands
okay question for you if you're watching
this
let's play this card here together okay
if you
think china is the bigger enemy than
russia
put thumbs up if you think russia is the
bigger enemy than china
put thumbs down we're at 77323 right now
they're really enjoying this today's
podcast yeah they're really enjoying
there's a part in there there's a thumb
like this and a thumb like
this i see that yeah so 773 to three
buddy it's basic technology i don't see
that okay who is the bigger enemy
china or russia thumbs up for china
thumbs down for russia i'm actually
curious to know where this goes from
here okay why don't we talk about
india's farmers
because uh this is a very the biggest
protest ever in
human you guys know the number how many
people protested a quarter of a billion
people
participate in a protest basically every
adult in the united states
basically every no no every adult in the
united states is one-fifth
every working adult in the united states
is 150 a quarter of a billion
people protested in india this is
ridiculous
why india's farmers are protesting for
nearly two weeks ten thousand tens of
thousands of indian farmers have camped
out on new delhi to protest a set of new
farm bill passed by countries parliament
countries parliament in september
thousands more
from the neighboring states of harayana
punjab and uttar pradesh
look to set to join in coming days even
as police try to block them
uh from entering the city these protests
are not isolated movement on november 26
an estimated 250 million citizens
participated in 24-hour general strike
held to challenge the new laws 24 hour
on november 26th
this the magnitude of the protest should
not be a surprise
agriculture employs about half of indian
workforce although it accounts for only
one-sixth of india's gdp some of india's
farmers are among the country's poorest
people
but government policies have long
protected them from the ravages of open
market prices
they cannot enter contracts with private
companies a practice known in india's
contract farming
and sell those but some of them are
hoarding anyways there's a lot of stuff
going on there
obviously india's millions of farmers
are clearly
angry they believe the new rules will
open them to exploitation by
giant companies and as baracta dude
writes in washington post
there's broad national sympathy for the
protest the moral force of the indian
farmer cannot be underestimated she
argues describing scenes of the elderly
protest
spreading blankets under the wheels of
their trucks to sleep in the cold winter
there is subliminal collective guilt at
the sight of farmers
thoughts man my heart goes out to them i
mean these people are making on average
a month and you're thinking to yourself
here in america well you know these are
indian farmers how does this affect us
well if you uh peel it back a little bit
um that's 68 of the world spices that
they produce in india it's 40
of the cotton produced in the world
basmati rice
comes from india they're the largest
milk producer in the world
and they're the second biggest producer
in fruits and vegetables
so it's unbelievable now weren't we
supposed to like that
what you're saying that's very powerful
the world is affected by it totally the
world should be paying attention
i mean this affects clothing you know in
so many different things
and we were all led to believe that this
new prime minister of india was supposed
to be this progressive guy
you know he's the one behind it yeah
he's the one behind it
but now he's trying to sell it like this
is going to be more opportunity but what
these individual farmers are worried
about is you know the big big factory
farms are going to come over and take
over
everything and you know what here's the
other thing too and if you really want
to get
conspiratory here if could you weave
china into this
i mean china is it a possibility that
they have something to do with this too
to get this protest going during kovid
to maybe lead to more deaths in india i
mean during these protests people are
going to be close together i don't know
but this is a big problem and i hope
they get it solved
250 million people
protesting 24 hours how long did they
protect 24 hours
uh november 26th how many stores were
looted
god knows right i don't know hopefully
they
but look i don't know much about the
indian farming uh
economy whatsoever so this is where i'm
gonna uh
pass the ball back to tom he did his
research but
250 million people that is absurd i mean
there's how many billion i mean
one point something billion people that
live in india mm-hmm are they gonna
are they they're more than china or
they're passing china not yet but
they're gonna pass china i don't know
who's that making babies what's the
popular what's the population in india
versus china china's got a 300 looking
population in general
china's got a 300 million lead i believe
india is 1.35 billion oh they're about
to pass up china they're about to pass
china by when
i mean at this pace it's not far off
yeah but go ahead make your point no
there's no point here it's just there's
there's a shitload of people in india
and
clearly this is affecting india this is
affecting the world
250 that's like if every single person
an adult in america
protested in one day 300 in the last 20
years farmers have been affected by
the regulations for a long time this
isn't a new thing this has been going on
for decades it's nothing new
but in the last kind maybe this is not
not a bad video for us to make similar
to a u.s china trade war to to make this
video i think it's actually a very good
idea to make the video i think it would
get a lot
in the last year yeah i know i we have
i've been to india you know we had a
great time with india our audience
you know we we love the indian folks and
they're
very hard-working people and i kind of
like that capitalism has helped them out
a lot they're coming up aggressively
they went from being a
non-issue gdp wise i think they're in
the top seven
right now and climbing aggressively
and i think they they can still they can
compete for the top three spot
in no time uh gdp gdp no question
between u.s brotherhood let me put it to
you this way
some of the best engineers in america
are indian we've got a couple iit iit
produce
of course we do they're geniuses iit
produces some of the best engineers in
the world there's a study that was done
where they went to do a market research
they went on the mit campus
and then they went on the iit campus to
see who produces better engineers and
they gave them some basic tests
here's a wire here's a battery here's
this make this light turn on the mit
people they don't know how to do it the
iit is like what do you mean this is
elementary this is nothing to us
and this kind of term so iit produces
ridiculous engineers so
india's going to be competing in the
last 20 years do you know how many
farmers people who own farms do you know
how many of them have committed suicide
in the last 20 years in america or india
in india
how many have committed suicide
specifically in the farming industry
what do you think the number's gonna
last 300 000 of them have committed
suicide the last 20 years when they're
only making 140
a month how are you going to take care
of your family this is a v
and by the way you know farmers it's not
like a sexy thing you do
you know you're like what do you i'm a
farmer oh my gosh she's a farmer you
know you nobody sits there so sick
when somebody says i'm in the military
what do you say ah you know thank you
for your service bro it's all good right
when a war happens you kind of like
these soldiers to go to war when you're
getting arrested somebody's breaking
into your house you kind of like cops
when all of a sudden the cost for what
you're buying skyrockets
you're looking around getting pissed off
at people you realize what happened over
here well
regulation farmers you're hurting them
yeah the big corp remember when we did
that one conversation with chad solomon
the owner of that
the rancher the the he was talking about
meat and what's going on with meat
prices in america where a handful of
companies are really controlling
everything and it's forcing
meat prices to go up and you now don't
know whether your meat is from america
or not because they don't want to put it
on there so it doesn't say made in usa
you don't know if your meat you're
buying is from china or not go ahead
even when it's made from made in says
made in usa it could just be packed in
the u.s
it's packed in u.s but it's made
somewhere else so they're pushing for
the farmers in u.s want to push to say
that this meat is made in usa
the big companies are saying no we don't
care if it is or not we just will say
we'll pack it in usa
but we sell it at a price and then i ask
the question i said how many people
actually care about the fact that
you know where your meat is uh produce
and people say it matters to me when's
the last time you checked
and everybody's like i never checked
that's the point so then you start
looking at ranchers and saying huh
these ranchers are more important i
never thought about ranch what does a
rancher's day look like
what do they do listen ranchers farmers
these people what they do is very very
important and it's very sad what's going
on to india
i hope i would encourage them to not
stop voicing their opinions and where
they're at and hopefully
eventually someone's going to turn i
know it got ugly a little bit you know
you know you had the government got in
you're talking about guns and you know
it got very ugly if you've seen some of
the rights that's not looking good well
and the other too is
you think of you think of them as maybe
a little bit more reserved or docile as
far as their character and whatnot but
the passion you see in these photos
with these protesters man this is
everything to them you could just tell
you know they're not gonna go away this
is gonna be a battle for that government
to try to win well something that
that resonated with me when you were i
make a note of it for video i think
that's definitely a video given
uh your impassioned point right there
was we've learned the term i went on the
terms that we talked about when it came
to work you know obviously uh hybrid
work model virtual decentralized but one
of the terms that we've
come to learn is essential worker yeah
farmer is an essential worker it's not
the sexiest job
unless you're going i think there's a
website called farmers only i don't know
how i know about that but
farmers only but uh check out only fans
of farms only but these are essential
workers
that is good okay that is good hey by
the way you know about farmers
yes of course you know of course of
course i know parmesan
wouldn't it behoove us as a country to
become aligned with india as much as we
can as big as they've becoming with
these i think so
i think so too because they're a
democracy they're the largest
share common enemy and they have a
stronger backbone towards china than us
how many apps have they banned from
china
150 apps or something like that i kind
of like if we're gonna if we're gonna go
against china
you know uh yeah no it's good to have
india on our side look listen this
podcast the attendance keeps getting
bigger and bigger i wish we had more
time with you because we've got so many
different topics a quick shout out to
mark cuban we take a lot of shots at
mark
regularly i do want to give a shout out
to mark cuban one of the things about
mark
is you got to give props to him being a
ridiculous owner
like seriously the guy is a phenomenal
owner to play for
this guy ends up signing giving j.j
berea 2.6 million i don't know the exact
number
2.2 million 2.2 he gives him two points
what's the number
minimum he gives them a 2.2.6 million
dollars last week
after he gives them 2.6 million dollars
they release them
so here's 2.6 million then i release you
respect and like look
thank you for what you did for this team
for this 11 years he was a scrappy
player too he was a scrappy plus he was
married
did you know that from a real miss
universe very cool that one up very cool
i've got a funny jj berea story actually
here we go
so you know a lot of the a lot of the
nba players
um party of mine party in miami they
stay they you know winter in south beach
um and you know one of my best friends
is chris humphries played in the nba for
you know 15 years recognizable guy six
nine married kim kardashian the whole
story he called you the other day he was
with his
current girl yeah yeah with his girl his
lunch uh when we were building lego i'd
like to take that weekend back in my
life
but uh we didn't break the record
i bet chris was impressed when you said
you were playing with him he's like oh
i'm out here in south beach where are
you at bro i'm like
i'm here with my friends playing lego
world's largest mike he's like cool i'll
catch you later buddy i'm going to go
back to uh
uh doing my thing but so this is like
the height of the whole thing this is in
like 2013 2014
you know mavericks beat the the heat in
the finals and chris was on the
mavericks whatever whatever whatever
and people came up he was on the title
team he was not on the title team this
was a couple years after that but
point is he was at the height of his
fame recognizable and these kids came up
and they're like hey chris can we get
your autograph we have a basketball get
your autograph and i'm like you know
like
he's given the autograph and they're
like you're not going to get his
autograph they're like who are you
i'm like i'm jj perea man what are you
talking about like you're jj berea
let me sign that ball for you buddy
there's a kid out there that's got a
chris humphries
and jj berea signed basketball
but it was the soy boy mafia we did it
again y'all oh my god but
that was shout out to you thank you
though yeah so i mean i didn't think i
was going to say it was lebron i went
with jj berea
shout out okay so shout out to cuban yes
it's good for him for doing what he did
with
jj brown the question is if he gets
released and comes back and signs
another team and hits a big shot against
the mavs in the playoffs
but again i respect owners that take
care of the players you got to give a
shout out to somebody that takes care of
his players having said that gang if you
enjoyed today's podcast
push that subscribe button we're trying
to get this thing to 100 000 subs to
make it something that we'll do more
often i think once we crack 100 000 subs
we'll probably consider going three or
four times a week but until then uh uh
you know we're probably gonna be once or
twice a week once it gets to a hundred
thousand subs we will probably put more
time into this podcast because we're
having a lot of fun with it
and uh we think a lot of good comes out
of this having said that thank you for
being with us the last two hours
have a great next 48 hours because we'll
do it again on thursday then we'll take
next week off
so we'll see you guys in the next 48
hours take care everybody bye bye bye
bye
you